this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists
man i don't even know where to start
this one today yeah we're going to talk
about
addiction we're going about sex and porn
addiction how to recognize it how to
break it
if it is a thing maybe it's not a thing
i don't know yeah i thought we'd bring
lisa ann to talk about it yeah
we sans here today kind of the perfect
person to talk about this hello
youtube thanks for being here wonderful
to see you both in person you know what
purpose you've put into my life and i'm
so forever grateful for your work
uh your documentary started my journey
and then your books
and then action and it's changed my life
that is awesome i love how you say
action because that is the most
important part to any journey like you
got to take action you can get all the
inspiration in the world
but if you don't take the steps then
yeah it'll it'll fall flat you know we
were just talking about that
new documentary it's out the social
dilemma we just did a podcast episode
with the gal
jess who runs our social media by the
way shout out to jess she's the one who
got lisa ann
on uh the show today and um
it really set up the problem the social
dilemma didn't it terrified me in a way
but i don't know whether or not i'm
prepared to take the actions necessary
to change that and
what we're trying to do with minimalism
is show people that like
there are some steps that you can take
to move yourself in the right
direction we're addicted to a lot of
things we're addicted to stuff
we're addicted to drugs and alcohol and
then some people might say that we're
addicted to you know we hear about sex
addiction or we hear about porn
addiction
and i want to start with this email that
i got from one of our patreon
supporters who uh i'll leave his name
out because it was a
it was a private message but he says hey
guys i want to thank you for
all your hard work and the value it's
added to my life i just want to send a
quick note
regarding something i've noticed on the
podcast over the past couple of years
i've been negatively impacted by
pornography in my life
i am in my mid-20s and on into the best
of my memory i started to experience
what i would qualify as an addiction to
porn when i was 10 years old
it stole from it stole from my
relationships and prevented me
from living a meaningful life the more
i've learned about porn
the more i believe that at its nucleus
it is an industry that primarily exists
to take advantage of people
and leave them in bondage to something
they deeply regret
i know many like you josh who speak
openly about their
enjoyment of porn and what it might be
or what it might add to their sex life
however i struggle to justify that with
my experience and what i have learned
porn has taken from so many friends and
acquaintances
to state it plainly sometimes i feel
like your comments surrounding porn
are a little cavalier in light of what i
understand to be the experience of a
significant number of people
to me participating with the porn
industry feels incongruent with loving
people
and using things i truly hope you
understand my comments come from a place
of genuine love and concern
um and so yeah he goes on you know to
sign it there but
lisa ann let's talk about this because
i do believe it can be a problem now
i've done some research
for this episode and it seems to me that
there isn't a real agreement
as to whether or not it's an addiction
and it certainly is
if it is an addiction it's it's
dissimilar in terms of
the brain chemistry from say an alcohol
or drug addiction
but let's just say we can take that off
table say it sounds to me
like this gentleman here some people
let's call him tim some people like tim
struggle with pornography so
let me ask you how old you are i'm 39.
so he's in his mid-20s which is the
ideal age to have
this problem and i'll tell you why
because when you were younger it was not
quite as accessible on your phone
true the problem with adult content
though we have it
labeled as 18 and up i'll give you an
example right now if i went on the
street
and i sold a dvd to a minor i would
still go to jail for 15 years
because you're selling adult content to
a minor but yet any minor can go on the
internet and click the green
green box that says he's 18. so what i'm
finding is
from the women i speak to and mentor
that are in their their mid-20s
and the men that i speak to in their
mid-20s they had
a phone too early they had access too
early and because of the rush what they
were watching created
the addiction started this chemical
balance with them
that they couldn't look away from that
they couldn't stop
looking at and they went down the rabbit
hole deeper
and deeper and deeper now you probably
know what your
taste is right yeah you know what you
want to watch sure you're you're not
young
and just clicking more boxes you're not
going into a category that you know
truly you feel
the women are disregarded and maybe
disrespected
and maybe there's violence or you're not
going there but a young kid will
if he says at 10 he started watching
then he went down all of these curiosity
rabbit holes because think about how
curious you are at 10.
i'm glad content wasn't accessible when
i was young i'm 48. me too
you had to go to a store and you had
you're right they checked your id
i mean it was vhs it was buried in your
dad's trunk
in a closet you know magazines barely
showed anything
someone his age spent so much time when
he says it robbed him
i get that because it creates
expectations
of what they would think meeting a girl
is going to be like what she's going to
do
and when she doesn't do those things
he's like why would i bother with this
this is a lot of work i could just go
home watch my porn
yeah so now it allowed them to
kind of sacrifice real engagement real
interactions real
intimacy they don't know what real
intimacy is they know that rush they
felt starting at 10 years old
to watch stuff that they were not old
enough to process
it's awful that we allow young people
that type of access because it ruins
them
for so many years of their life sexually
yeah yeah and
so let me ask you this what is the the
solution to that to the young people
be having access to obviously parents we
need to be engaged
we can't be with them 24 hours a day
though so it does seem to me like
there's some responsibility on the sort
of pornhubs of the world
to have some sort of ability to filter
out
young kids so i spoke last year at the
oxford union on this topic
uh because some countries are trying to
divide an id
card that is like your driver's license
you would have to scan this in to be
able to access the content it would
prove how old you are
some places are trying to do like an eye
scan but there are countries that are
already ahead of the us
because in the us this drives traffic
and it makes money
so we're obviously not going to
eliminate it here but in other countries
they're working towards that sweden is
working towards that
england is working towards that because
they see it as a problem in other
countries like finland
australia their content is not the same
of what we see here when my company
wants to distribute to some countries
there can't be any violence there can't
be any gagging there can't be any like
the angles are different it's almost
soft core
because they know they can't regulate
the internet there should be
you put your id in there the problem for
parents is
not checking where their kids have been
looking on the internet you know kids
will clean the cachet
you know delete their cookies but you
know it's also synced in with video
games so when your kid is playing video
games
pornhub is driving traffic to these
devices and all of a sudden a window
comes down with boobs and the kid clicks
on it oh my gosh where am i now
and now the rabbit hole begins so we're
feeding it
and very guilty of it in this country of
allowing kids to have it
and they're not offering sex education
on it in school they're not teaching
like i try to tell young people
porn stars are like stunt people they're
most likely going to do things that a
lot of other people
will never do so don't expect it in the
real world and also understand that
their pay scale
graduates up for those types of scenes
so when you meet the girl and take her
to the dance she's most likely not gonna
do what you saw in the movie
right right yeah the the stunts that's a
fascinating way to put it right because
um the truth is you can you can watch
and enjoy you know
a tom cruise stunt double do or maybe he
does some of his own stunts i hear right
but
regardless you can watch that but when
you try to replicate it yourself you
often get hurt now
i think this is what tim is saying here
he's getting hurt sort of metaphorically
now ryan he
that line that he really said that stood
out to me here was to me participating
with the porn industry feels incongruent
with loving people
and using things but it doesn't seem to
me that it's
binary like that that almost sounds like
what he's saying is it's a little bit
too simplistic yeah it's
it's porn bad no porn good
and that seems to be moralizing it in a
way that
i don't feel it doesn't feel true to me
yeah i guess
you know given our topic of minimalism
and helping people find balance it's
like how do you help
someone find balance because yeah it
can't just be this binary thing
uh you asked how do you get kids to or
how do you like you know
monitor kids internet bro browsing or
whatever it is
you can get uh it made me think of
parental controls
so like i know on cell phones like
verizon has this thing where you can
you know for five bucks a month you have
parental controls if they go to a
website you can get a notification hey
your kid
went to this website yeah and we do that
with ella's ipad and
yeah there are different apps you can do
for that so i think you know when
like if a parent gets that notification
it's not about like punishing that kid
and making them feel bad for it
poor and bad it's also not just doing
nothing you know porn good
but it's an opportunity to have a
conversation about
you know what pornography is what's
appropriate what's inappropriate
you know to sit here and say that you
know it's
involving ourselves with the porn
industry is
uh the opposite of loving people and
using things and i think that there is
some pornography you can get to
that when it does have violence when it
has these really you know
crazy genres that um totally
you know are are violent i don't know
how else that's necessary
yes exactly they're unnecessary yeah 100
consider that but
it doesn't need to be eliminated because
it is like you know it's like going out
for a decadent dinner or having a
decadent dessert there's people who just
like to get decadent and watch something
but they know the
content that makes them feel good
whether you're single whether it's a
couple
you know whatever it is there's still a
lot of good content it's like sifting
through it just like
anything else and for him the effect
that it had on him very young
left him jaded by it because he feels
guilty
about how it's changed the way he fused
women and sex and he probably didn't get
to have a lot of great
sexual experiences on his own because
they were always led by the thoughts
that they're not good enough because
they're not what he
saw for all those years watching it that
is such a good point it makes me think
of this stat
about jen i think it's jen's ears
they're having
the least amount of sex than any other
it and it has to be
the least amount of sex of any
generation lowest teen pregnancy of
any generation part of that sounds good
but then my guess is it
might be for the wrong reasons though
right it's not good it's part of what
you saw now i'm watching the social
dilemma tonight
okay um my neighbors and i are all
getting together because we think this
is a good conversation piece where you
should watch it and then sit
and talk about it afterwards so we're
getting together to watch this um
it's about what your what your reason is
now i have a lot of young girls that
have told me they've had one sexual
experience that scared them and now
they're not having sex at all that's the
gen xers
and that's from the young guys at 10
watching porn and thinking it's okay to
choke a girl the first time they have
sex with her and she's like
what just happened here i'm never doing
this again their
phones are more important to them than
their vehicles like there was a survey
last year
would you rather have your parents take
your car away for a year or your phone
every kid shows their phone because they
can use their phone to get an uber
right right they don't want the
responsibility of the car yeah the same
thing is going on with communication
they can talk with their friends here
but why bother it's so much work to meet
in person
and to meet in person means then you
have to try then you have to engage then
you have to try and like make that move
to hook up
the no sex thing i think is very
unhealthy yeah yeah
and to me like when i say it sounds good
and that's because we're in a rather
moralizing culture
right that that puts a premium on and
by the way we even use weird language
around it i
took her virginity really what did you
do with it
can you give it can i give it to someone
else right yeah
she was a willing participant yeah she
shared it with you right and by the way
yeah and now that she doesn't have it
what what am i able to do something with
with it like we we use this language
without even realizing like that's a
very normal
thing for us to use but it should be
abnormal the way that we
the way that we talk about sex is often
guilty or shameful and we even have a
question about that
in a little bit but before we get to our
audience questions
let's let's make this sort of case
against porn in the case
for porn because i think you're the
perfect person to talk about both
because
we see that it's hurt tim's life here
and it's hurt a lot of people's lives
probably because of early exposure there
are probably other reasons as well
but also it exploits certain that in
that industry can
exploit a certain number of people as
well so maybe let's talk about the bad
side and maybe we'll talk about
the potential upsides of it the bad side
so you know when i started shooting in
the early 90s there really wasn't a
bad side yet as uh female performers you
were kind of
praised catered to craft services called
you the day before what do you want
you were treated like gold because not a
lot of women wanted to do this right
so you were still treated like we don't
want her to run off and like move back
home
it wasn't jenna jameson didn't arise yet
this didn't become
mtv-ish pop culture-ish so we were
celebrated even
how the man disrobed you on set had to
be very sensual
and soft and no rush it was then illegal
to do choking and smacking
and anything rough the girl always had
to look equally in control
by law to be able to distribute this
type of content
so because the laws were right here we
had no internet
everybody stayed on board and it was
this really kind of
everything was sensual and sexual and it
was a bunch of really sexual beings
in the industry from in front of the
camera to behind the camera and then
came the internet
and the realization that we need tags we
need different tags so when people put
in keywords
now we have these tags so now we have to
do these 10 extra things
in this movie and it just became a thing
and not a beautiful substance of sharing
you could learn something from a porn in
the 90s
that was intimate the caressing i mean
there was like
30 minutes of caressing and foreplay
back then
because the sex was so much shorter and
they didn't show full penetration
so they had to fill that time the angles
were from the side i mean
and it was this thing and then here
comes the internet here comes gonzo and
it's like we got to get this much in in
23
24 minutes and we got to cover all these
categories now
we removed the sexual element of it and
made it a total business
that would cater to key words how is
that sexual so the downside with that is
that
and then the industry affects the weak
when it comes to talent so the downsides
that i saw
of men that would hire men that would go
into malls by high school and find
18 year old girls and say do you want to
make 20 000
a month and of course the girl that
watches the kardashians
every day and everything i need channels
she wants to make twenty thousand
dollars a month she wants to get her
hair done
buy clothes you know she knows exactly
so the luring in of the uneducated to
sign paperwork that then
kind of gives away a lot of their rights
and them being so afraid to say no to
the money
they start making sexual choices and i
always told everyone never do something
on camera for your first time
so if you haven't been with a girl on in
your personal life why would you do a
girl girl scene on camera
oh what a good point like in it's just
like it anything like
the first time we did public speaking i
wouldn't want to film that and put it on
youtube i was 22 years old it would have
been a nightmare yeah
but that's what's happening now and now
also like i think there's a premium for
that as well
we even call it amateur or whatever
right now now
we there's something about us that that
gravitates toward
i don't know maybe it's the there's a
versatility or a realness
to to it's more intimate you're seeing
in you know someone isn't telling them
what to do it's just vulnerable
yeah yeah yeah and so when
we are consuming some of
this material if it's someone being
exploited we're actually doing
uh harm to we're doing the opposite as
tim says here
yeah we're not loving people and using
things we're commodifying people and
that is
the opposite of what ryan and i want to
do so we have to be careful
not to consume something that has taken
advantage of other people
and i would say that obviously extends
beyond porn it extends to the clothes
that we wear or the food that we eat
right yeah now but there is a uh let's
say there's a potential upside
to this as well um you talked about in
the the 90s where it was a lot more
loving
in a way so let's talk about even even
today
i think there can potentially be an
upside to have a healthy
relationship with porn yeah and there's
companies now that are working towards
those goals of making beautiful quality
products
and when couples watch it together they
have something geared towards
them you know wicked is a company that
for years has made
beautiful products with a little bit of
story lines they kind of remind you of
those old cinemax films where they would
almost get to sex but they actually do
they always use condoms and that's
something they wicked took upon
themselves to promote in their movies
which i think is really important
because it shows that as part of the
role
but it's about knowing what you're
viewing researching it and i'm sure
you've all heard of only fans and
everybody talking about only fans
only fans is doing well because all the
girls are producing their own content
right so you know no one is forcing them
to do something
and it's really been neat to watch them
turn into
turn away from being workers that often
take
roles for money that they don't want to
do and then just going
i want to make cupcakes topless this is
what i want to shoot today and the girl
shoots it
and has a great time doing it in her own
kitchen and then puts it up on her own
only fans like there's something simple
about that but you have to look for
couples porn
you have to look for healthy porn and
understand that a lot of the stuff
you're gonna find on say pornhub which
you brought up is
most likely more graphic than anyone
needs to see that's only here in the us
we should we should be
we should really be regulating that a
lot more because those are young girls
and i have a lot of friends who as
they've gotten older and their children
have gotten older
like i can't watch porn anymore because
now i see girls are like almost my
daughter's age and i'm like
that happens that's a normal association
now you feel a little guilt
because you're worried does this girl at
18 know exactly what she's doing
search out couples porn search out porn
where the performers are a little bit
older the companies are a little bit
different there's some
all-female run companies that are
putting good content out there but
it is healthy it is an outlet but i
think when people are alone and young
and watch it
it it forms their mind too much and
that's why the 18
was such an important age like i wish
it was 21 to shoot i wish talent
couldn't shoot it before 21. if i could
ever change one thing
because a girl from 18 to 21 changes so
much that's when you get the tattoo you
regret
and then you have to get it removed by
24. you know that's when all these
little things happen so maybe
by 21 she would evolve to to finding
more options or maybe she would still
say i mean i waited till 21
even though at 18 i knew i wanted to do
it i was just turning 21 when i made my
first trips out i was already writing to
companies in the business but i just
wanted to be sure
i wasn't making a permanent decision i
was dancing at 18 and meeting porn stars
and asking myself for two years
is this really going to be my choice and
it was yeah that's a great point we've
got some audience questions here we're
going to talk a lot more about shame and
guilt and
and the upsides and downsides of this
struggle with pornography but let's hop
into some of our questions here
first one is from ari in boston i
remember that josh mentioned in the
previous episode that it's important to
have
a partner with a similar sex driver
libido even if you have a partner with
an aligned sex drive
how can one apply minimalism to either
increase
or decrease the sex that is going on in
your relationship
so in the past i think i've mentioned
that my wife and i have similar sex
drives and that's really good for our
relationship i'm certainly not um
mapping that on to every relationship
i'm sure there are some relationships in
which
there are radically different sex drives
although i think that would probably
cause some tension so
can we talk about libido's role in a
relationship and i think maybe that's
leading to all some of these
porn problems that we're having where
one person may have an appreciably
different
libido from their partner yeah i think
some of it starts from
comfort where you become a little bit
complacent and then maybe a little bit
lazy
right and then you have to roll that
back in and say to yourself oh i
remember how excited i was when we first
moved in together
and i knew we could have sex whenever we
wanted as opposed to
when we went on our date on friday or
saturday night right
having those thoughts in your mind and
reminding yourself of that excitement
and and kind of finding that way to
spark that
and connect that without being too
intrusive right because sometimes
someone gets home they're exhausted
you're not in sync but one of you is
ready and the other isn't
setting that stage how do people set
that stage
i tell a lot of my guy friends if your
girl's working late and you're afraid
that this might be a night where it
doesn't happen make sure you like tidy
up the place before she gets home
do little things so that when she gets
home her mind has less weight
and she is free and also she's turned on
by that
she's excited by that she was driving
home thinking about all these little
chores she was going to do now she
doesn't
now here you are can be a simple candle
can be it was a wedding gift i always
buy the bride and the groom a cologne
and a perfume that i tell them to never
wear
anywhere except they wear it on their
wedding day and then they wear it at
home on special like as a
as a scent trigger of like let's get at
it tonight you know what i mean
don't wear on a regular thing don't
worry about a date to go out to dinner
only in your home
yeah that's so good that scent reminds
you of that day yeah
well i think too like he's out he asked
how can minimalism help you
have more sex in the in in your
relationship um
going back to you know we're just trying
to help people find a middle ground
yeah so uh how going to your partner
going to your
wife or husband or whatever and saying
hey look um here is my
values when it is when it comes to sex
here are my desires
and you start that conversation and see
exactly how maybe you two can get on the
same page now maybe one partner does
have a higher libido than the other
so then the question is is go out of
your you know how can you go out of your
way
to show your partner that you want to do
everything that you can for them to make
them be
uh in a sexual mood i know like with
with with my partner like i will um
ask her you know hey what what what can
i do for you i don't like talking about
our sex life too much like but but this
is an appropriate time i guess to talk
about it
but uh you know it'll be something like
she'd be like you know i really want you
to like pick out a nice pair of shorts
for me or uh or or a nice
a nice like lingerie thing for me or um
hey let's pick out a sex toy together
and like those things uh i pay attention
to um if i didn't ask her
i wouldn't know to do that thing so so
let's let's talk a bit about
libido and and its role in
a good relationship a healthy
relationship with
a partner um i think sometimes it's one
of those weird things where
we feel like we can't talk about our
desires
even with the people closest to us or
maybe even especially
with the people closest to us and
and i think that that creates some
tension in the relationship if i were to
get back to ari's question here
maybe i would say you know at least in
my own relationship one thing that has
helped us
is uh bex will often pick a porn for us
to watch
and so it often is the more sensual
woman directed exactly what you were
talking about earlier
and in doing that it helps me better
understand you know even though we have
similar libidos we obviously have
different preferences
and it helps me understand her
preferences what works for her
and then communicating is really key i
can't tell you how many
relationships i was in before this
relationship
i communicated really well in every area
except sex
and i i'm not sure why that is
you two probably have a more honest
connection and the fact that maybe women
in the past
felt like they wanted to put a porn on
but they didn't know how you would feel
about it and then they overthought it
and then they just refused to do it
right
she feels comfortable enough with you
that sets the stage it shows you
something different it's a little bit of
like
even the bad music in the background of
a porno it gets you kind of it's just
like it's it's a dragon thing right it's
not great music but
it gets you there you might even need
none of you fully focused watching it
it's just starting it and igniting that
maybe that conversation they didn't feel
comfortable enough having people are
very held back by
being open and honest about their libido
and what they want
for you the little shopping trips the
little details the tiny things that's a
kickstarter
i think the most important thing is not
letting it go too long before you have
the conversation you know people will
say oh we haven't had sex in months
okay well at what point did you decide
to not go sit outside somewhere at a
park
and talk about it shouldn't be something
you can't talk about but get away from
all your stuff
i always tie nature in with
communication because i think sitting
outside
can really clear you of all the
pressures in your home your mail your
laundry your stuff
go sit outside at a park put your phones
in the car
talk about this let's get this ball
rolling you love each other
you want to touch each other you don't
want someone else touch you you don't
want to watch pouring behind each
other's back
right right you want to do this together
so you have to really work at that
yeah i think there was a part in a time
in my first marriage where
um things were just weren't working we
weren't compatible she's
a great person it just didn't work out
for us
and that did start happening where we
weren't watching porn together it was
like i'm going to watch this when you're
not home
yeah which is a huge failure right yeah
a huge failure
absolutely was and and instead of
communicating you know dan savage calls
it a former podcast guest of ours he
calls it ggg good giving and game
when you're in a relationship you you
want to be good at whatever you're doing
or trying to get better at it
in order to please the other person uh
giving
means you're not just receiving that's
often a a problem especially many men
have is uh being the receiver but never
the giver
and and then of course game you're
willing to do anything within reason
sure right and that's going to be
different for each person reason
can be way way over here for one person
and but but
being willing to sort of expand those
boundaries together
i found has really our sex life now
we've been together over five years it's
way better than it was when it even
started
and that's the opposite from virtually
any relationship
i've ever been in actually it's
definitely the opposite of any
relationship i've been in
and and so it tends to wane over time in
many relationships because
you have that chemistry early on right
there's the early chemistry
but then the rest of the relationship
sort of you you get comfortable and that
chemistry
yeah yeah and so i think if anything
ari um what you're looking for is that
that good giving and game
helps you avoid that complacency which
is so important all right i'm going to
send you a copy of our book everything
that remains there's a chapter in there
about how to screw up a relationship
it's uh
the first love of my life i really
screwed up and
uh right right and i wrote about the
lessons i learned from that so
it's a memoir called everything that
remains uh ryan and i wrote it
a few years ago and if you like our
podcast you'll like the audiobook
version of everything that remains or if
you want the book book or the ebook
version
happy to send those to you as well i'm
going to skip
kalina's question and head right on into
the lightning round ryan
all right it is time for our lightning
round where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts
go to both of our phones now
lisa and during the lightning round for
ryan and i and our guest we do our best
to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 character
response
but not really we just wonder friendly
yeah ultimately they expanded it
we we uh we monitor on a bit and
eventually figure out something that's
uh tweet worthy
podcast sean puts those in the show
notes so people can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media
we call them minimal maxims derek has a
question for us
what are your thoughts on the difference
between guilt and shame
being a primary trigger to lead someone
to become
addicted to porn you know i think it's
really fascinating and i have a
a article that we're going to talk about
on the maximal episode
um because i do think that
part of what's going on right now with
the the shame and
guilt around sexuality and thus
to porn has to do with we've been
acculturated to
be ashamed of our bodies of sex of
sexual expression
right how did you get over that because
especially
the time when you started it was a giant
leap for you to have to make
and did you ever struggle with guilt or
shame at all before or
after um i struggle with everyone else's
you know everyone else's guilt and shame
was projected on me to the point where
i can't tell you how many apartments i
was denied access
uh banks i was denied service you know
in the late 80s early 90s
as a girl in this industry taking money
into a bank there were women that would
just
not deal with you they would just send
you out so i dealt with
not feeling it myself because to me this
was my choice i just tell people like
you're letting this bother you and this
doesn't bother me i'm a sexual being
i had three very simple goals at 16
which was to travel and see the world
make my own money and make my own
schedule adult life
porn fulfilled that for me you know what
i mean i got to see the world so
the guilt for me is only when someone
projects it on me you know like
sometimes i remember in my dating life
like
i'd go on a date with somebody i think
they'd be really into me and then i
realized like oh they want me to explain
to them how i deal with my guilt
and i don't have any guilt which they're
gonna be bothered by because they have a
ton of guilt
and they need me to pacify them so that
they can consider dating me
because really they just wanted to see
what it would be like and now that they
think they kind of like me they don't
know how to process the information
right
it's a very select person to process the
information
we shouldn't be ashamed of our bodies i
have a much more european mindset
whereas they're so
open in other countries we're so held
off that's why porn makes so much money
because if we
make people think it's it's bad then
they want it more like drugs alcohol
cigarettes but have you
um so for me it's not my guilt i mean
i've been
i've had especially during the pandemic
when the world was closed i sat down
with myself and said
how glad are you that you took every
[ __ ]
chance you could here we are sitting
locked in our places with
i have no regrets yeah i've had sex with
people in other countries that never
spoke english i worked in
on sets and in a whole room of people
that spoke different languages and our
only common language was sex
and i feel so liberated by these choices
that i made in these chances that i took
so people have to understand that you're
the
guard of your own thoughts when it comes
to shame and guilt
criminals feel shame and guilt right
they're sitting in a cell and they have
to sit and think about what horrible
things they did
that got them there which is awful
sexually you shouldn't feel
shame or guilt let's talk about shame
versus guilt here
let's have a quick pity answer and then
we'll unpack it here
guilt tells us something about our
actions but shame says something about
our identity so ultimately if we do
something
you said as a criminal you might do
something once it doesn't make you that
person
you made a mistake or a bad decision
depending on those those are two
different things but maybe you made
a bad decision that doesn't mean that's
who you are as a person but if you're
that person who continues to
rob bank after bank after bank you're
probably a bank robber
yeah right you're that person yeah yeah
and so ultimately you're going to feel
shame because that's who i've become
i've become this person well guess what
how do you change that shame it's by
stop doing the actions that created the
guilt that ultimately created
the the shame and now what we're talking
about here is not of specific
action sex isn't the thing that we
should feel guilty about
humans have always done it are we are we
going to act like that's not something
that's it's been happening for 200 000
years uh
plus uh in humanity and and so that's
not the thing to feel
guilty about what we feel guilty about
is this
this moralizing that has happened in our
society and
ryan and i we we have different beliefs
we have similar values though so we
bring a lot of different people on the
podcast the first time you were
scheduled to be on here
uh there were some covid related things
you weren't able to make it we had a uh
a pastor on that same day instead right
i even told i haven't told him that his
name is erwin mcmanus and uh but he's a
different kind of pastor who isn't a
moralizing sort of
person in fact the the church that he
started he didn't let christians come to
it for the first couple years
because they're too judgmental he was
afraid he was
because he he himself was a christian he
was afraid that christians were going to
ruin
his chris his sort of christianity in a
way because he was he didn't want to be
judgmental he wanted to create
this thing for people who i want to
create a space
of openness and i think that's what
we're talking about right now we're
talking about whether
it's it's porn or we're talking about
any of our other proclivities
um we need the space to to even talk
about these things
and i think even a conversation like
what we're having right now can be
incredibly taboo for some people because
because of the guilt that they're
that they are feeling and it doesn't
mean that you have done something wrong
necessarily it means that you're
told the thing that you want is wrong
that your desire is wrong that your
human tendencies
are wrong but i don't think that gets us
very far
no yeah i think uh
it's interesting because growing up as a
jehovah's witness
they are kids are getting married at 17
18 years old because they're not allowed
to have sex before marriage so they
don't want to live in sin so they end up
getting married and i can't tell you
how many of them end in divorce or worse
they're still married and can't stand
each other
so i mean it's it's uh it is so
important to question why we feel guilty
in fact
my pithy answer is this uh learning from
your guilt
can help you avoid shame so
if you watch porn and you feel guilty
that is a symptom of something and
you've got to ask yourself why do i feel
guilty is it because
i'm told i should feel guilty is it
because
i had this sexual experience without my
partner i mean to examine why you feel
guilty that's really what's going to
help you
move forward and then you learn from
that guilt either you learn something
about
your morals or you learn something about
uh
you'll learn something about yourself if
you don't learn from your guilt then you
will get to a point where you start to
be ashamed of who you are so the bank
robber who's robbing multiple banks
eventually is going to be like well
i'm a bank robber so that's what i'm
going to do sheriff accepted it yeah
yeah and they yeah
they reconcile with okay i have to
become now i am this person i've become
the sort of
the the bad guy i love what you're
saying here ryan about about
guilt because well i think in
uh where was i going to go with this
there's so many ways to go with it yeah
yeah yeah um
so if if someone is feeling guilt
because the society has propped them up
some way we call it a
a memetic belief right it just means
that society has said something is
is wrong or taboo
and we may not feel that intrinsically
that something is
is wrong or taboo and so
there's this cognitive dissonance now
lisa ann you were able to avoid that
cognitive dissonance in a way
and um how you i know you you mentor
younger i would call them kids now but
people in their 20s
they could be my children okay yeah and
many of them come to me because they can
have conversations with me
that they just don't feel comfortable
having with their parents or
friends their age i love having younger
friends because younger people keep you
so inspired i mean their level of
movement now they're so creative every
young kid knows how to edit
create do everything from a laptop like
you could take them to another country
and they'll put you out 10 youtube
videos you know what i mean like
the things they know how to do but yet
they haven't had those conversations
with their parents
uh they're very intimidated by porn you
know think about being a young
woman and trying to watch porn for your
first time
it's much more geared towards men than
it was when i started in the 90s there's
not a lot there for them then it makes
them afraid
oh are these things going to happen to
me when i go to have sex with a guy
yeah so i'll tell young people for every
one porno scene
you watch i want you to read a romance
novel
because when i grew up all of my aunts
read these
romance novels and so eventually i took
one i realized
oh my gosh this is reading porn yeah
they're pretty steamy
they're so steamy they're so steamy and
yet but yet they get the juices flowing
right
but then there's a cliff because you
know you have to visualize your own sex
scene
but see that's a really good thing for a
young woman because if you take that
next step and you visualize the sex
scene you're almost creating what you
think turns you on
you're visualizing what this man would
look like how he would touch you
as you're reading this so i think we
need to kind of roll it back that's a
really good sex education
is playing the mental game with yourself
getting your heart racing a little bit
and feeling it
rather than they just go to it i mean
there's so much kissing talk in those
romance novels i was young i was like 10
i was like
why did my aunts read these things like
cover to cover and then i got it
we don't offer that in porn right now so
i think for me teaching young people to
roll it back
to be limiting what they're watching but
also to trust each other and to
want to touch and see how it feels you
know
when i was younger we were a little bit
freer we would have more experimental
sex
we would talk during it you know we
weren't as held back i think this
generation is a bit more scared to do
that because they're afraid
we'll get out on social media somebody
might take a photo somebody might tell a
friend
oh i was with him and he couldn't get it
up they're
so afraid of their peers yeah
we didn't have that who was going to
tell and if they did who was going to
believe
them right but back then people didn't
speak about it gossip about it they
respected it yeah this this
enhances the sort of guilt right what
you were talking about earlier like
if you feel if you watch porn and you
feel guilty from it
um that that may be the case but the
guilt could stem from several reasons
sometimes the guilt might be justified
like when i talked about earlier my
first marriage
i should feel guilt for that because
what i was doing was hiding something
not that i was watching porn it wasn't
the porn that was the problem
in that relationship it was me and it
was our compatibility that was a problem
in that relationship and so i felt
guilty not
because of watching the porn and this is
just in retrospect but i felt guilty
because i was hiding something from
someone that
i loved and you weren't sharing your
needs with that person either you were
handling them on your own you felt very
selfish guilt about that
too absolutely because now you knew she
wasn't going to get taken care of either
so in the back your mind you had guilt
about that as well
yeah and and so when i
when i finally came to terms with like
hey maybe it's not
the porn that is the problem here
at least in that relationship it was
a lack of communication uh unwillingness
to be myself with the person who's
closest to me
and i was putting up a sort of facade
right
and so i think that and then eventually
the shame came in because like well i
guess i'm the type of person who goes
and like hides in his office and
masturbates to porn instead of having a
difficult conversation with my wife
that's that is a problem and that's when
porn becomes a problem but then now
in my marriage now it is
it's sort of an augmentation it's an
amplification it's not
a crutch we don't use it regularly but
when
it if even if we did that'd be fine but
what happens is
we use it when it's when it feels
appropriate and
decadent yeah yeah i love you know i
loved i loved when i was on the road and
i'd be at strip clubs and there'd be
couples that would come in
once a month they would go out for like
a nice dinner and then they'd go to the
strip club together and it was just
their thing they did once a month and
some of them were really just people
watchers right but it was something they
shared that was so unique and it just
made me happy
in the late 90s when i started to see
couples evolving you know when i started
the owners didn't let women into clubs
so even if you were a couple
the owners back then would say well
these women will take away from my women
making money and they'll be
fights over these women i'm like no
these are couples that want to come in
and do this together and maybe share in
a dance and
talk about what they like in a girl and
then of course that you know they went
home and had great sex
right and finally this started to evolve
and it made me very happy because i
would see couples and the girls would
always treat them really well too
because the girls were like this is so
cool you guys are doing this together
and
it was it was their thing just like you
guys watching something together it was
just kicking it up a little notch
together yeah so if we were to sum this
up would we say that
porn is a problem when it when you
become dependent on it just like
or and or when it gets in the way of
living meaningfully
and that i think you could sub you could
substitute porn with alcohol
because it's not inherently evil right
you can substitute it with
work there are workaholics where that
just destroys their life
right but no one's saying well i guess
we should stop working now
because one guy happens to be
addicted to working no we what we need
to say is there's
a responsible amount that we need to
figure out that's appropriate for our
own lives
and so the bad seems to happen when it
gets in the way or we become dependent
on it
the good happens when it enhances
amplifies our experience of life
i also think the bad happens when you
are too young
age plays a huge role in this i mean
under 18
haven't had any of your imagine your
first experience
is with a porn and not with a a girl
yeah
so i think it's age when it came into
your life and then how much free time
you had to watch it
i think it being accessible on phones is
really creating havoc and that's why
when he said mid 20s i was like
bing bing bing i know exactly what his
problem is he was locked in his room
watching it for endless hours a day for
probably
five ten years yeah and that creates an
unhealthy relationship with
other people because they're not
actually uh you know you're not seeing
them necessarily as other people
at that point right and you're not
engaging no you're not you're not
engaging with other people you're not
going out flirting with girls you're
just sitting and watching something that
can be
really distracting and really disturbing
yeah and it can ruin you in a lot of
ways
another thing dan savage often says he
talks about death grip syndrome i was
just thinking that
yeah i mean i don't know if you're
familiar with this but
basically it's you know guys who
masturbate so frequently they're
they're unable to you know just get off
with another partner yeah
and i think that what's happening is
your mind all of a sudden now associates
associates
horniness or attraction with that
glowing screen
as opposed to that other human being who
is remember the stunt people that are
acting like they're enjoying it
more than they actually are that it is
shot with a fisheye lens that makes the
guy
look larger than he actually is where
there's tons of lubricants to make the
girl look
wet like everything about it is
amplified like a stunt movie like a
stunt
so it's such an unrealistic you know
when i did my speech at oxford union i
said 99
of what you saw on the internet don't
ever ask a girl to do any of that for
you
you know it's not going to happen and
you're most likely going to offend her
and freak her out
so reel it in reel it in but there's so
much they see and i think
too young is very destructive yeah all
right we want to talk about
kinks coming up kinks kink shaming
uh are certain kinks appropriate
inappropriate
before we get into that we also have
some listener tips and an added value
segment today but we do
have a bunch of surprise questions this
week like are minimalists less
susceptible to porn addiction
will our youth become more addicted to
porn with the easier access of today
also what's porn look like in the future
what's responsible porn look like in the
future
can appropriate porn viewing actually
help someone's sex life
will addressing trauma and sexual trauma
help break some of our addictions also
is pleasure
inherently immoral plus a million more
questions
for lisa ann and the minimalist and if
you want to hear all that subscribe to
our maxwell episode
over on the minimalist private podcast
it's a completely separate podcast
and it's the most honest way for the
minimalist to earn an income because we
don't believe
in advertisements by the way if you're
not a private podcast supporter you're
literally missing two-thirds
of our show so go ahead and try it out
for a month
if you don't get immense value from it
you can always walk away you can set it
down
if it's not adding value to your life
but it's worth way more than the two
dollars that we charge
head on over to theminimalists.com
support to subscribe and get a personal
link
so that our maximum episodes play in
your favorite podcast app
ryan what else you got for us this week
here are some voicemail comments and
tips from our listeners check them out
hi my name is maz from uh cypress
california
and um i do have a tip um for all of
your clothes
and your shoes that you aren't in need
of right now um i'm not sure if
hospitals are
accepting it because of covid but um as
a nurse i know that when i discharge a
lot of homeless patients
um we can't discharge them in the
clothes that they came in with you know
either they're dirty or you know um it's
just
uh season wise it's just colder and they
don't have um
thick warm clothing so if you are able
to find a hospital that is accepting
donations then
that would be the best place since a lot
of hospitals
we can't really discharge patient
patients and gowns
and we don't really have a lot of shoes
so that would be the best thing
hi josh and ryan my name is parker and
i'm from ventura california
i just wanted to offer up a really cool
resource for anyone who is a free
thinking individual
and wants to become more politically
involved i myself find it nearly
impossible
to truly understand and take a stance on
certain polit
political issues with the amount of
polarizing news and media
that supports the narrative there really
is only the right side or the left side
the organization i want to share is
called braver angels
and it is a group that seeks to make
politics in the united states
less polarized through thoughtful
discussion and debates
it holds formal debates where people can
deliver speeches on extremely prevalent
issues
there are time limits and questions as
well as all training positions
throughout the whole debate it is a
truly refreshing and hopeful way to
experience politics
so i highly recommend it all right y'all
thanks again to lisa anne for joining us
today
check out her podcast it's called the
lisa ann experience if you want to
follow her on twitter and instagram
she's at the real lisa ann
and she also has a youtube channel at
the real lisa anne as well we'll put a
link to those in
the show notes thanks again lisa anne
for joining us today
helping us have a meaningful
conversation speaking of meaningful
conversations for our added value this
week ryan
we already alluded to him earlier but we
might as well talk about it
one of my favorite podcasts is the
savage lovecast dan savage
former podcast guest of ours um not in
studio but we were doing some of the
quarantine conversations and
we were able to capture that uh with him
had a great conversation with him
but he i mean part of our podcast we
we take voicemails from people i
originally got that idea
as a mix between dan savage and um dave
ramsey
and and and our show is obviously
different from both of theirs
but i think the key is we try to help
people out in different realms with
with dave ramsey it's money with dan
savage it's uh saxon relationship
advice and his his podcast
the savage lovecast is so i mean
bex and i will often listen to it and
we'll say how do you think he's gonna
answer this question
how do you think he's gonna answer this
question i subscribe to the ad free
version of his
um and because he has a ad version and a
longer extended
ad free version and it's totally worth
it to
get it completely ad free but uh even if
you don't if you want to check out his
podcast i would just download the most
recent episode
they're not theme they're just numbered
so it's like number 716 or whatever
you just go to the most recent episode
and and check it out
listen to him answering some questions
and you'll realize that oh
there's a totally different worldview
and many different worldviews about
sexuality
and about shaming
and not feeling shame with respect to
our sexuality and
having a healthy relationship
with intimacy and
and man it's just a great podcast savage
lovecast
i would encourage you to check it out uh
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on
in the life of the minimalists ryan
has finally started an only fans account
[Laughter]
for only 50 a month you see a bunch of
pictures of cucumbers
you'll see why they call him the greek
freak
that is not true no yeah there is no
only fans account although
shout out to you if you have one uh ryan
has decided he hasn't pulled the trigger
on that just yet
so instead of going to ryan's fictitious
only fans account
one thing i'm going to recommend for you
is we're talking about
shame today we're talking about our
values really
and i think it's about getting clear on
what your values
are a lot of the things that we've we've
discussed today
uh questions that we're answering they
really have to do something with our
our values and you can't really act in
accordance with your values if you don't
know what they are and so we have a free
values worksheet
and an essay that you can read and in
fact in that essay i even go through my
values we have identified four different
types of values it's like building a
house
you got to have a foundation you then
you have to have the structures you have
foundational values structural values
surface values and imaginary values
and i think quite often the imaginary
values are the things we think are
important
but they're not actually important at
all yeah and unfortunately we waste so
much time
on those imaginary values and they get
in the way of what's actually important
so
we want to help you identify what your
values are which fake values are getting
in the way
and you can download that worksheet for
free you could just fill it out
it's a beautiful beautifully designed
worksheet our friends over aspire
designed it for us and read the essay as
well the minimalists.com
v to check out how to understand your
values the essay there and also
download that free values worksheet you
can follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimalists
come to one of our live podcast shows
visit theminimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist
and if you want our show notes and your
inbox sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
our simple
sunday emails whenever we send those and
if you leave here today with just one
message
we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it